et on ouvre donc ce débat par les hubert
files avec des invités emilie zapolsky
bonsoir vous êtes communicante
fondatrice de l'agencé et midi-conseil
j'accueille également jean garrigues
l'historien vont souffrir du comité
d'histoire parlementaire dans soir jean
auteur de la tentation du sauveur il
soit une passion française c'est chez
payot richard vers libres soir soit
revenue avoue correspondant france
europe pour le média suisse blick rappel
le titre de votre livre la france contre
elle-même a publié chez grasset laetitia
cru pas éditorialiste politique bonsoir
laetitia certes la bienvenue à vous il
paraît que j'ai bombardé emmanuel macron
lise de l'écologie évidemment c'était
passé rodez rue du haut des titres été
misés l'économie fumiste bref c'est une
erreur c'est un lapsus et donc il fait
bien ministre de l'économie au moment de
ses liens avec hubert les yeux verts
fase donc révélée par ce consortium ce
sont plusieurs médias européens réunis
en france en l'occurrence le le monde et
et et radio france peut-être sur la
gravité de la faire parce que je sens
que c'est assez intéressant d'avoir
votre avis aux uns et aux autres
là-dessus mise appel ce qui je commence
avec vous est ce que vous jugez que
cette affaire est grave globalement on
sait que ça arrive et c'est normal c'est
ce que disait d'ailleurs hors berger ça
arrive que le ministre de l'économie
discute avec des entreprises pour savoir
comment s'implanter comment faciliter
c'est c'est ça aussi les mêmes
heureusement qu'il leur est heureusement
c'est l'attractivité simplement c'est
vrai que ça c'est une vision très
libérale de l'économie quand même eu
bercé des modalités de conditions
travail on le sait quand même au
lance-pierre cd indépendance était d
indépendance qu on essaie de reconnaître
comme des salariés qui sont quand même
pas très très bien payés donc c'est une
vision très libérale et ça redonne à
emmanuel macron cette image qu'il avait
au tout début de son quinquennat
président des riches pro-entreprises
très libérale sa fédération
voilà c'est là dedans et même moi ça m'a
fait penser aussi pendant le quinquennat
il ya eu beaucoup d'accueil d entrepôt
logistique d'amazon aussi pendant ce
quinquennat et c'est pareil c'est la
même chose c'est à dire ok c'est de
l'économie de l'avenir on peut pas dire
le linverse c'est quand même des choses
qui vont se développer mais c'est
choquant que comme si on privilégie et
ça et puis c'est vrai qu'il ya quand
même l'histoire choquant des sms très
directe comme ça révélé comme ça ça
donne une drôle d'impression
d'un ministre en effet lobbystes mais
très direct je pense que ça vient un
proche un peu proche par rapport à
quelque chose qui serait ouvertement des
réunions des rendez-vous qu'on estime
normaux là on a l'impression qu'il ya
des choses qui se passent un peu en
coulisses un peu très directement des
échanges de sms goethe arrange le coup
en gros ça passait un peu mal et ça
intervient il me semble à un moment où
emmanuel macron est quand même en
fragilité d'ailleurs on le voit pas
beaucoup on le voit juste
l'international il a du mal à gérer
cette assemblée nationale qui est quand
même un gros bazar sait que c'est
compliqué à l'heure actuelle je trouve
que ça intervient pas un bon moment il
est déjà fragilisée ça lui redonne mais
quand il revenir évidemment les
conséquences politiques à plus long
terme jean garrigues est ce pour autant
une affaire d'état j'ai entendu certains
élus d'opposition employer ce terme
alors je crois pas que ce soit une
affaire d'état ce serait totalement à ce
que vient de dire emilie est un aspect
un peu choquant voire une proximité
excessive d'un ministre mais ce sont des
pratiques qui ont toujours existé il ya
20 ans avec quelques collègues et publié
un livre qui s'appelle les groupes de
pression l'histoire politique de la
france et des états unis ont montré que
depuis 150 ans les groupes de pression
quels qu'ils soient et lobbys n'ont pas
cessé d'agir mais même très directement
sur des détenteurs du poids exécutif là
ce qu'était ce qui est embêtant c'est
que ça s'est fait un petit peu dans le
dos du premier ministre du ministre de
l'intérieur que manuel valls et est bon
ça ça effectivement ça ça ne fait que
renforcer un peu cette impression de
proximité excessive des manuels valls de
macron pardon avec un certain nombre de
avec will à la start up nation va dire
maintenant c'est pas un scandale d'état
parce que il n'y a pas d'enrichissement
personnel il n'y a pas de conflit
d'intérêts a priori on nous parle d'un
deal les journalistes qui ont écrit les
articles mais c'est normal ils font un
petit peu de comment dire de
sensationnalisme ya pas de deal n'ya pas
il n'y a pas quelque chose que que le
général dolin
un moment à un moment on nous parle
éventuellement de la récupération d'une
entreprise maury ducrocq qui aurait
permis de sauver un certain de d'emploi
et qui aurait été sans doute bénéfice
politique pour madonna qu'on ne s'est
pas fait donc voilà que qu'emmanuel
macro et étaient impliqués mais
d'ailleurs il l'a dit lui même qu'il
était partisan de ce type de dubé
risation de de la société
ça c'est un vrai débat c'est moi je
souhaiterais d'être un tout petit peu
dans le contexte de l'époque sais pas ce
que vous en pensez gervais relie mais on
peut pas dire on est que les taxis leur
monopole avait forcément bonne presse en
france et que tous les urbains étaient
des vent debout contre l'arrivée des vtc
replace on est aussi un peu dans le
concert est très serré chars vers l'est
quand on prend un peu de recul européen
vous savez la suisse par exemple un pays
libéral hubert pose des questions
notamment les questions fiscales parce
que ça hubert a quand même tout un
dispositif pour éviter de payer des
impôts dans les pays où il est le plus
imposé c'est le cas en france et y est
son chiffre d'affaires est pour
l'essentiel porté sur une holding aux
pays bas donc dans beaucoup de pays
européens la problématique hubert et les
fiscale c'est une entreprise qui fait
tout pour ne pas payer d'impôts et à mon
avis ça c'est une polémique justifié en
france il y à une autre polémique et la
polémique elle est sociale et elle est
assez spécifique à la france parce que
c'est comme ça le système française qui
les ya un mot qu'on n'a pas prononcé ici
emmanuel macron était quand même
ministre d'un gouvernement socialiste et
donc de ce point de vue c'est grave oui
de ce point de vue c'est grave parce que
il était dans un gouvernement qui avait
10 ans pour mission des objectifs
sociaux auxquels il a contrevenu parce
qu'il était déjà à l'époque obsédé par
une chose qu'on peut reconnaître comme
une qualité alors là c'est l'élément du
débat c'est l'attractivité de la france
et la nécessité d'y ramener des
investissements étrangers et tout le
monde ça n'aura pas échappé que cncc
révélation paraissent le jour même où il
ya le sommet de choses france avec je ne
sais combien de temps je crois
leurs étrangers invités par emmanuel
macron au château de versailles
dis-donc donc là il y en gravité qui
tient au débat politique français parce
que dans le débat politique français au
fond la récompense de ce lobbyisme c'est
à dire l'attractivité et le fait de
venir des entreprises de faire venir des
entreprises en france et bien cette
récompense elle n'est pas jugée comme
suffisantes elle n'est pas jugée sur les
tisseurs vous a pas entendu elle est
assez simple en fait est ce qu'il ya une
faute politique est ce que en tant que
ministre de l'économie il pouvait passer
ce type d'accord sans en prévenir ni son
premier ministre ni des ministres qui
est aussi à s'occuper de ce sujet qui
apparemment était contre voilà est-ce
qu'il ya une faute politique parce que
la tomate vous parliez de l'opinion
publique qui finalement accepté de façon
assez favorable cdtc mais elle épingle
du point de vue des manuels macro y est
il oui ou non une faute politique
l'elysée a déjà répondu avec bombannes
vous connaissez ce type de réponse un
peu formel en disant que finalement il
participait à la mutation profonde qui
était déjà engagée depuis plusieurs
années en dénouant certains verrous
administratif ou réglementaires très
bien mais ça c'est vraiment la réponse
première réponse de com de crise 1 on
attend effectivement un petit peu plus
de l'exécutif qui est se mouiller pour
savoir si oui ou non mais les
journalistes aussi peuvent savoir si oui
ou non il ya faute politique lehbila pas
s'empêcher faire quand même un parent a
elle aussi avec une autre affaire c'est
celle de mckinsey parce qu'à ce moment
là pendant la pandémie le gouvernement a
fait appel à ce cabinet de conseil
américain qui au niveau international
est carrément tâcher de nombreuses
affaires de corruption il faut le dire
et pourquoi on a fait appel à mckinsey
pour déverrouiller pour surmonter des
bureaux administratifs
il ya quand même chez emmanuel macron
cette tendance à faire confiance aux
autres plutôt qu'à son ami et c'est pour
ça que ça m'intéresse de vous entendre
sur les effets d'image à plus long terme
ça rejoint un peu ce que vous disiez
dans votre réponse vrai qu'on creuse ça
sert que ça fait ça fait deux ans que
par les crises l'état providence et
maquereau est devenu le symbole de le
durcir évidence en france et là c'est le
maquereau libéral qui ressort de chez
lui c'est ça qui est étonnant c'est
qu'on a vraiment un état qui est devenu
un chéquier sur pattes qui distribue
énormément qui nous protège cabot
coûtera protéger l'économie en cas de
défaillance d'entreprise ça commence un
tout petit peu mais c'est vrai qu'il ya
une protection à la fois des salariés
des entreprises ça fait réapparaître
cette image un peu mauvaise de
libéralisme que les français n'aiment
pas tellement avec en plus les
conditions de travail d hubert qui des
chauffeurs eux mêmes et moi je dirais
même plus c'est c'est encore plus
profond que ça refait jaillir quelque
chose qu'on ne voit pas beaucoup c'est
ce projet de société cette espèce de
libéralisme parce que on a parlé du
beurre on a parlé d' amazon on parle des
dark store aussi vous savez les darks
torse et les petites boutiques qui
permettent de livrer n'importe où dans
une métropole qui sont favorisés aussi
on a une espèce de deux moulinettes
comme ça qui s'avance d'un système quand
même très libérale où on accueille en
effet des investissements étrangers mais
quelles que soient les conséquences sur
le territoire français je prendrai juste
un exemple il ya eu un gros scandale de
saint gobain qui disait moi je suis
concurrencée par une entreprise indienne
dans le grand est qui a des subventions
qui non seulement est accueillie on lui
offre tous les infrastructures le
terrain on facilite où les collectivités
s'y mettre parce qu'évidemment c'est des
emplois on la subventionnent donc de
l'argent français qui va dans ses
caisses et qui concurrencent une autre
entreprise française donc ça fait
apparaître un emmanuel macron près en
effet pour l'attractivité de la france à
vendre des morceaux de la france et à
faire de la réindustrialisation
mais un peu à n'importe quel prix ils
compris en estrie en détruisant des
entreprises françaises et c'est là où je
pense qu'il va avoir un problème avec
des oppositions que ce soit le
rassemblement national qui lui veut
revenir aux nationalistes c'est à dire
on défend nos entreprises et on arrête
de donner tout aux étrangers et puis à
la fois côté nuxe qui défend des
conditions de travail social parce que
ces conditions de travail que ce soit
amazon ou hubert ou des entreprises
comme ça faut pas rigoler elles sont pas
au point par rapport au standing con
qu'on s'impose en france mais qui est
plutôt pas mal alors justement va
écouter l'une des voix de ces
oppositions c'est celle de du communiste
fabien roussel
un président de la république en
exercice doit pouvoir être auditionné
malgré tout malgré qu'ils font en
exercice sur des faits aussi graves que
ceux là quand même on peut pas attendre
2027 pour l'interroger alors jean
garrigues là ça m'ouvre un autre
chapitre dans ses bagues l'achat le
chapitre de l'immunité présidentielle
d'une éventuelle commission denquête
voilà est-ce que oui ou non il faut on
peut entendre un présent la république
écoutez moi je suis pas un juriste
peut-être faut interroger quelqu'un qui
est très précis sur ces questions mais a
priori je ne vois pas qu'on peut
auditionner un président de la
république en exercice donc on sait bien
que jacques chirac a été soumis lui
aussi en quête que investigations et
qu'il a été condamné après être avoir
quitté son sont là l'elysée donc bon et
je ne pense pas en plus profondément la
qui est matière à ce type alors qu'il
commission denquête moi je trouve ça
très sain donc commission d' enquête
parlementaire c'est ça ça fait
fonctionner la démocratie les contre
pouvoirs etc et on peut avancer vers la
vérité
un directeur de mercier ainsi les halls
de l'époque a travaillé sur le sur le
dossier pourquoi pas mais qu'on en sache
plus et que ce soit là la représentation
nationale qui nous le disent moi je
trouve ça très très très bien très
importants comme la vérité la commission
pénale a par exemple la commission
denquête de du sénat ça c'est cette
résultats sur le
le sens de la démarche des manuels
macron etc on peut aussi discuter parce
que le le le on voit bien que la part
des investissements étrangers en france
a beaucoup augmenté depuis quelques
années que le chômage a reculé jeudi il
ya un bilan quand même qu'ils nommaient
jeu en fait ce qui se passe c'est qu'il
me semble-t-il sur le fond des choses
les démocraties libérales comme les
nôtres elles sont elles sont confrontées
à un choix entre une l'emploi précaire
et le non emploi donc lui c'est un
libéral qui a choisi l'emploi précaire
un peu à la manière de gerhard schröder
il ya 20 ans donc voilà à partir de là
si vous
par exemple il ya les emplois précaires
on en avait parlé ici à 1,01 euro et
voilà les ont pas vraiment précaire et
hubert a été pendant un temps je ne sais
pas si c'est encore actuelle mais
interdite donc voyez il ya des choix
aussi qu'ils sont au dessus et qu'on
sache si beau et bien sûr il ya des pays
qui ont déroulé
moi à titre personnel et encore une fois
vu avec un peu de recul européen je
trouve dommage que le libéralisme est si
mauvaise presse en france d'une manière
générale parce que le libéralisme il
s'est quand même du bien l'économie et
il est nécessaire à la vie de l'économie
non ça c'est une opinion et en france
malheureusement ont tout de suite on
commet une faute
dès lors qu'on défend le libéralisme il
faudrait quand même pas entré dans un
procès politique permanent parce qu'on
est libérale et qu'on pense que les
entreprises doivent pouvoir travailler
par contre une différence avec
l'allemagne gerard schröder ce qu'il a
fait il l'a fait cash devant le
parlement c'était des lois qui ont été
débattus toutes votées par la majorité
c'est pas des trucs qui se sont fait
comme ça en dehors à coups de sms c'est
ça la cia faute c'est là qu'elle est la
vôtre c'est à dire de ne pas finalement
avoir joué la carte de hubert
politiquement parlant ça aurait pu être
le cas parce que visiblement on comprend
qu emmanuel macron n'était pas soutenue
sur ce dossier par son premier ministre
juste une chose quand même aussi c'est
qu'on ne peut il y à investissements
étrangers et investissements étrangers
hubert n'investit pas dans des intras
tonnes ou non et donc autant on peut
peut-être considéré que certaines
concessions seront normales pour toyota
qui fait une usine de voitures à
valenciennes autant on peut se poser la
question sur hubert d'autant qu'il ya
cette question fiscale à la clé alors
vous l'avez évoqué mais cette cette
affaire si l'on si l'on peut dire en
tout cas la sphère hubert files elle
pose effectivement la question du lot
bling et je propose à quand un calme et
de nous de nous rejoindre il ya bonsoir
et bienvenue à plusieurs lois qui ont
été votées par le parlement pour
favoriser la transparence autour
justement de l'action de ces lobbys
voilà et puis la dernière la plus
récente c'est la loi sapin 2 votée en
décembre 2016 à la fin donc du
quinquennat 2 françois hollande et qui
formule en fait la toute première
définition du représentants d'intérêts
c'est à dire du lot east et cette part
elle crée également un registre commun
des représentants d'intérêts en fait
toute personne dont l'activité a pour
finalité d'influer sur une décision en
entrant en relation avec les décideurs
publics il est maintenant tenus de
s'inscrire auprès d'une autre autorité
indépendante l' achat tvp la haute
autorité pour la transparence de la vie
publique en clair donc toute entreprise
toute personne privée et qui cherche à
changer la loi et pour ce faire et qui
rentrent en relation avec le
gouvernement ou avec des parlementaires
bien ils doivent comme cela présentait
montrer patte blanche devant cette
autorité administrative
la loi prévoit quand même des exceptions
les partis politiques associations
d'élus partenaires sociaux ou encore les
associations cultuelles mais les autres
sont considérés comme des lobbyistes
il doit fournir une déclaration annuelle
qu'ils font sur ce site là que vous
voyez avec les détails de leur activité
une fourchette de leur chiffre
d'affaires et les détails des moyens et
dépenses liées aux actions de
représentation d'intérêt et quel est le
bilan de cette loi après cinq années de
mise en oeuvre d'applications il est pas
très bon le bilan thomas on peut le dire
la haute autorité pour la transparence
avis public elle juge cette fois plus
que perfectible c'est didier migaud qui
l'a dit vous voyez à l'image c'est le
président de cette taille il a dit
notamment dans son dernier rapport
publié le 1er juin dernier sur les
répondeurs d'intérêt dit il on est très
en retard
2391 entités sont désormais inscrites au
registre répertoire il dit on a bien
progressé avec la loi sapin 2 mais ce
n'est pas parfait par exemple certains
lobbyistes ne sont pas inscrits car il
faut un certain nombre d'actions auprès
du parlement ou du gouvernement pour
s'inscrire c'est dix actions ça a été
écrit dans le décret d'application de la
loi une fois qu'elle a été votée par le
parlement et donc en fait si c'est le
gouvernement qui est un qui invite ou un
parlementaire là aussi pas besoin de
s'inscrire c'est uniquement si le
lobbyiste veut lui aller 20 l'exécutif
ou intentions nationales donc didier
migaud il ajoute une partie de la haute
administration fait un peu du blocage
sur la définition des représentants
d'intérêts il y a un vrai blocage et
didier migaud qui nous a dit le 1er juin
dernier que par exemple il a cherché à
rencontrer bercy des ministres ou même
le souhaitent un général du gouvernement
et bien cette réunion elle a mis deux à
trois ans à être organisée il ya
beaucoup de bonnes volontés merci
beaucoup quentin c'est le moins que l'on
puisse dire est et emilie zapolsky c'est
intéressant le la place des lobbys et
ont rejoint ce que dit un peu ce que
disait richard wehrli sur notre rapport
au libéralisme à l'argent aux sociétés
privées et leurs rapports avec les avec
les ministres ou les les députés ou ceux
qui écrivent la loi
c'est l'opacité qui est la difficulté
l'opacité on sait que ça existe depuis
des lustres et c'est relativement normal
chacun joue sa carte et essayer de
négocier d'influencer les lois les
règles les décrets les réglementations
ça ça me paraît normal moi ça me choque
pas ce qui me choque en effet c'est le
manque de transparence et quand il ya
des choses vraiment en coulisses qui
sont réalisés ça c'est beaucoup plus
choquant et vous l'avez dit c'est vrai
que ce n'était pas quelque chose
d'affiché mais mal inverse puisque
c'était sous un gouvernement socialiste
donc ça va quand même à l'encontre des
promesses de hollande je suis contre
finances
et demi c'est la finance la sasa
s'entrechoquent sur le libéralisme je
pense que la france n'est pas totalement
opposés au libéralisme non mais quand on
connaît pas beaucoup de politiques qui
s'affiche ils se reconnaissent comme
libéraux non mais par contre le mineur
on a beaucoup de matches d'emploi on a
beaucoup le dernier qu'il l'assumé je
dirais que c'est alain madelin
beaucoup de mal à s'aguerrir à au
libéralisme et au code je prendrais
juste un exemple pendant la crise qu
vide et d'ailleurs l'allemagne a pas du
tout fait pareil et on a copié
l'allemagne très rapidement pour
protéger les indépendants on leur a
donné une belle enveloppe de 1500 euros
par mois vous rendez compte c'est à dire
que c'est quand même les salariés on les
protège et quasiment à 100% et les
indépendants on leur donne et 1500 euros
par mois
sous conditions de ressources et rien
dire avait dit qu'on n'imagine même pas
la vie d' indépendants et même la façon
dont c'était calculé sur des factures
mais ça n'avait ni queue ni tête
rapidement on avait calquer le modèle
allemand en allant jusqu'à dix mille
euros ça veut dire qu'on est on est un
pays globalement de salariés c'est vrai
qu'on est un pays qui est beaucoup plus
d'entreprises de salariés de cdi et on
va devoir changer complètement
cette façon de réfléchir parce que de
plus en plus on est dans des cdd des
modalités de travail beaucoup plus
courte dans beaucoup plus d'indépendance
et d'ailleurs les jeunes demandent ça
aussi d'avoir plus de métier plus de
plusieurs travail peut-être dans une vie
ou même en même temps dans le même temps
donc on va devoir faire ça mais
simplement on a vu le libéralisme par
exemple en union européenne ça marche
pas tellement et ça marche moins en
temps de crise si c'est pas un peu
encadré et c'est ça je pense que la
france demande et de voir cette façon de
faire sous la table sans encadrement
c'est un peu limite et d'autant plus
quand on sort après la taxe gafa parce
qu'on a été les premiers français a
essayé de récupérer justement les impôts
de celle où on se dit mais alors on est
complètement schizophrène d'un côté on
leur dit venez n'importe comment et de
l'autre côté on essaie de les taxer il
faut qu'on puisse affronter ce à deux
faces pourquoi pas un libéralisme mais
encadré je voudrais un mot sur la
réponse attendue puisque je reviens sur
ce que demande et fabien roussel tout à
l'heure va y avoir une interview
présidentielle le 14 juillet et mâcon
renoue avec l'exercice
on peut imaginer que ce sera une
question sera le moment de l'arrêt c'est
un souvent été l'occasion pour pau pour
des présidents en plus ou moins
difficultés conjoncturelles ou
structurelles de justement de se
défendre et là on a connu ça avec
mitterrand avec chirac sont des affaires
différentes mais donc là c'est
l'opportunité pour le président au moins
de s'expliquer parce qu'effectivement le
vrai problème est il et il est cette
distorsion politique au sein du
gouvernement de françois hollande c'est
ça mais honnêtement moi je on peut lire
voyez ce que le ministre de l'économie
de l'époque avait un vrai poids
politique voilà c'était pas le seul
sujet sur lequel il avait pris une
certaine indépendance et croyez moi que
manuel valls ont été assez marc est
étonnant c'est que lui même ne supporte
pas quand un ministre reprend le minimum
d'indépendance un ou une ministre il ne
supporte pas qu'il a une tête qui
dépasse qaïda essaie de prendre le
contrôle de la présidence normale en
devenant un projet jupe irait à vue où
ça avait mené françois hollande on va
continuer laetitia des d'évoquer les les
éléments de langage vous avez repéré ce
week-end 2-1 nouveau message de
l'exécutif à destination des français
est la meilleure façon de saisir un tous
ensemble ces éléments de langage sont
les mots qui sont fabriqués qui sont
préparés en amont pour envoyer des
messages aux français et bien c'est
d'écouter un lieutenant des manuels
macron olivier verts en porte parole du
gouvernement c'était hier sur rtl faire
de la politique faut aimer les gens il
faut profondément aimé les gens donc
comme on aime les gens partez du
principe qu'on aime les gens sinon prêts
passés entre autres choses comme on aime
les gens il faut qu'on soit capable de
voir montrée peut-être davantage ce
n'est pas compté combien de fois le mot
aimer et prononcé mais vous avez compris
le message je vous aime voilà ce que dit
l'exécutif aux français et puis il y à
aussi à côté 1 la nouvelle méthode
qu'emmanuel mâcon nous avait promise au
soir de sa réélection
celle du compromis ça c'est le mot qui
était répétée par elisabeth baume dans
son discours de politique générale et
relayé par tous les ministres ensuite
pour signifier la main tendue aux
oppositions donc le gouvernement a
échoué à former une coalition donc il se
pose en négociateur avec encore une fois
cette main tendue
aux oppositions pour tenter d'apaiser en
tout cas les négociations futures et
c'est à rapprocher du contexte qui est
tendue à l'assemblée nationale et qui
pourrait le devenir aussi dans la rue
c'est toute la question qui plane sur le
début de son quinquennat est ce qu'il y
aura ou pas ce quatrième tour social
promis par la france insoumise mais non
pas que promis il est aussi organisée
parce que la france insoumise a déjà
prévu une date en septembre et des
grandes vacances d'été pour marcher
contre la vie chère c'est le mot d'ordre
et puis à côté d'eux des partis
politiques il ya aussi les organisations
syndicales on avait tendance à les
oublier sous le règne des manuels macro
mais la cgt est encore présente et
organise elle de son côté deux journées
d'action en septembre contre la future
réforme des retraites on écoute philippe
martinez qui était ce matin au micro de
france info
je le répète la première réunion
intersyndicale a eu lieu avant le
discours de la première ministre et le
fait qu'elle annonce
fidèle à ce que dit président de la
république il faut travailler plus
longtemps serait ce que j'espère que ça
va en énerver plus d'un récemment la clt
là la troisième chose donc les
mobilisations sociales me semble-t-il
sont du ressort des organisations
syndicales ça fait très longtemps que
c'est comme ça et que des formations
politiques soutiennent les mobilisations
sociales il y en a besoin mais il faut
pas de mélange des genres bon ils ne
sont pas datées aussi un message pour
les conventions ça évidemment mais ça
multiplie
les occasions en tout cas de descendre
dans la rue côté français et ça
l'exécutif en a pleinement conscience
thomas la menace qui plane c'est là
qu'elle c'est celle d'un retour de
flamme des gilet jaune évidemment
stigmates du premier quinquennat
d'emmanuel macro et donc les éléments de
langage qui ont été préparés ce week-end
sont bien sûr à destination des français
pour tenter d'apaiser cette colère
sociale mais pour le moment aucun
baromètre n'a vraiment mesurer la
puissance de cette contestation est
aussi sa capacité à se transformer en
mouvement de grève ou de blocage donc
septembre sera vraiment l'épreuve du feu
pour l'exécutif si en septembre il n'y a
pas de manifestations monstres qui
bloquent le pays l'exécutif aura réussi
son pari richard vers l'iss et on est
souvent dans c'est notre métier aussi on
se projette comme ça et souvent ce qu'on
a c'est ce qui est trop écrit n'arrive
pas ce que je veux dire
oui ce qui est certain c'est que la
volonté de de ce 4e tour social elle est
là il y à des formations politiques qui
ont un intérêt objectif à tenir ce cadre
d une tour social qui vont tout faire
pour moi ce qui m'inquiète et on et ça
nous ramène à la sphère hubert ce qui
m'inquiète c'est la l'extrême pauvreté
des réponses apportées par l'exécutif
jusqu'à présent c'étaient les réponses
sont pauvres les réponses ne sont pas
convaincantes sire que même si vous êtes
plutôt enclin à considérer qu emmanuel
macron avez raison du point de vue de
l'attractivité des entreprises ce qui
est répondu c'est pas convaincant de may
a pas de règle
absolue donc rendez vous le 14 juillet
s'il ne parle pas dissiper alors une
autre chose qui est inquiétant c'est
qu'il se trouve que j'étais ce week-end
aux rencontres économiques
d'aix-en-provence où on a eu un certain
nombre d' échanges avec des ministres
présents il y en avait 1 notamment bruno
le maire on comprend qu'une autre
réforme évoluent et celles de
l'assurance chômage et que du côté de
bercy on voudrait remettre sur le tapis
l'assurance chômage parce que pour dire
les choses clairement il faut selon le
point de vue du ministre des finances
revêtent les français au travail parce
qu'il ya beaucoup d'entreprises
qui ne trouvent pas d'emploi y est alors
là si vous venez maintenant avec
l'assurance chômage je ne sais pas
comment c'est possible jusqu'à mai mais
c'est une réalité on a
la grande émission le terme et être
formé des pénuries dans une google vous
faites là l'assurance chômage a déjà été
réformé
oui mais on annoncé une contestation
sociale forte à la suite de cette
réforme est bien
un peu trop écrits ou annoncés par les
par les journalistes et les
commentateurs n'arrive pas forcément
mais jean gabriel et il ya quand même
quand vous commencez votre réponse dans
dix ans la réponse est en disant que la
réponse du gouvernement est maître était
pour je pensais que vous parliez face
aux crises et aux et aux tensions
sociales or c'est ce que je disais tout
à l'heure la boîte à milliards est
ouverte depuis depuis deux ans
pour faire ça alors justement c'est ce
que j'avais je veux dire est ce que le
ferment des prochaines crises sociales
jean garé il est pas là vers le jour où
il va falloir et refermer cette boîte
argent magique où là forcément oui bien
sûr c'est c'est tout le pr c'est tout le
dilemme de 2,7 de cette situation sert
qu'on est dans une situation la logique
économique et financière tout cas celles
du gouvernement ça va être de refermer
la boîte alors qu'il ya une demande
sociale de redistribution de hausse des
salaires etc et que forcément les les
oppositions vont avoir beau jeu de de
jouer là-dessus et d'autre part le
rapport des forces parlementaires fait
que l'alliance et la direction de la
politique gouvernementale va forcément
vers l'est républicain c'est à dire vers
la rigueur vers le libéralisme plus plus
orthodoxes on va dire alors que je vais
être là domaine social va dans dans
l'autre sens donc a priori on va vers
quelque chose d'assez explosif mais
comme vous l'avez dit le pire n'est
jamais sûr je veux dire que il ya une
chose aussi de auquel on a assisté
depuis un certain temps c'est que on a
eu du mal à voir se coaliser les les
oppositions on a bien vu même au moment
de la crise des gilet jaune elle est
fille n'arrivait pas jean-luc mélenchon
n'arrivait pas
à capter l'essentiel du mouvement donc
il faut voir aujourd'hui un paysage très
très très fracture est très fragmenté ce
qui pour moi est très dommage parce
qu'il ya une occasion historique de
travail et de coproduire de la politique
enfin ça c'est un autre mois une somme
qui a des messages il ya des messages
contradictoires parce que en effet il ya
une tactique pour séduire un petit peu
les républicains donc on mar la réforme
des retraites donc la dette ça y est on
en remet une couche le discours est une
obligation j'avais dit rien sur pour
pour faire passer des lois et dans le
discours de politique générale
d'elisabeth bandes s'étaient présent
réforme et dette et de l'autre côté il
ya ces mesures qui continuent à arriver
parce que le quoi qu'il en coûte on
n'arrive pas même si gabriel attal dit
parle de maintenant de combien ça coûte
et plus de quoi qu'il en coûte on voit
bien que ça continue et en fait les
français quand ils entendent ces deux
trucs c'est le ressenti c'est le
ressenti qui compte c'est comme la
sécurité le ressenti sur le porte
monnaie il est c'est catastrophique
et comme il ya encore la guerre
d'ukraine il ya un peu une reprise du
coc vide moi je pense que c'est plutôt
là je suis d'accord il risque d'y avoir
eu quelque chose d'explosif parler en
centaines de millions aujourd'hui s'il
n'y a pas une annonce 100 milliards
c'est comme si c'était rien passé pas
possible et nous avons changé de
paradigme ou en tout cas une à traquer
de loi en faveur du pouvoir d'achat qui
va être recruté là donc ça va la dosi
changer la taille initiale de l'autre
côté la musique du gouvernement c'est de
dire on referme les robinets on est dans
le combien ça coûte fille ressenti des
biens gens il faudra
trois mille milliards de dette on n'est
plus le plus cher c'est ça qui fait que
l'on a commence à dater un peu chercher
le plus cher bon allez l'autre actualité
jours c'est évidemment la motion de
censure déposée par la nouvelle union
politique écologique et sociale à
l'assemblée nationale alors elle a été
défendue par matt hill panneaux la
présidente du groupe elle est fille on
les écoute
et puis juste après la réponse de la
première ministre pour résumer vous avez
été nommé par le président de la
république en mai puis au lendemain du
naufrage des législatives vous lui
présentez votre démission le président
vous a maintenu en poste et ce alors
même que vos idées sont minoritaires
dans le pays vous ne tirez donc votre
légitimité ni des élections législatives
ni même du parlement acquis vous n'avez
pas demandé s'il vous faisait confiance
pour conduire la politique de la nation
en d'autres termes vous est à cette
fonction une anomalie démocratique avec
votre motion de censure pas de bouclier
tarifaires et l'explosion des prix de
l'énergie pour les français avec votre
motion de censure pas de remise
carburant et 10 euros de plus pour un
plein de 50 litres avec votre motion de
censure pas d'augmentation des pensions
et un pouvoir d'achat amputé pour les
retraités voilà ce qui peut arriver
quand on fait passer la tactique
politique avant l'intérêt des français
vous avez inventé le concept de motion
de censure a priori il n'est plus
question d'un texte ou d'une décision a
dénoncé juste rassurer pour censurer la
notion de posture a remplacé la motion
de censure
richard wehrli c'est cette motion de
censure de posture elle permet aussi à
lisabeth bande de montrer sa pugnacité
c'est comme ça qu'on l'a vu cet après
midi bien de l'avoir mais sauf que la
censure c'est toujours une posture je
veille à la différence qu'elle fait la
réalité c'est que l'objectif d'une
censure c'est de faire tomber un
gouvernement
absolument mais là en l'occurrence donc
je trouve que la réponse est pugnace
vous avez raison de le dire ce qui est
intéressant dans la réponse est qu'elle
lit directement la motion de censure a
entre guillemets les avantages
économiques que le gouvernement est en
train de donner en disant si vous me
faites tomber vous n'aurez pas une série
d'avantagés économiques mais encore une
fois moelleux doute que j'ai c'est que
je trouve que il manque la un socle
d'éléments convaincants parce que
précisément et bien donner des aides
celle que citer laetitia savoir les 20
milliards pour le pouvoir d'achat
aujourd'hui c'est plus tellement
suffisant parce que beaucoup de français
ou en tête de toute manière ils vont
fermer la boîte est de toute manière ça
va diminuer donc je dirais la valeur
utile des subventions ou des aides qu'on
peut donner elle va diminuer d'autant
que par exemple sur le carburant la
grande question de la rentrée ça va être
les fameuses aides ciblées qui est-ce
qui est adroit qui est ce qu'il n'y a
pas droit et sur quels critères et là ça
va être compliqué ce sera notamment
l'objet note second débat on va parler
de sobriété énergétique
jean garrigues moi je retiens les mots
quand même de mathilde de panneaux
anomalie démocratique
c'est rude mais c'est faux
je commence à être vraiment scandalisés
par le discours de remise en cause de la
légitimité du suffrage universel que
tiennent mais c'est une stratégie
politique et que tient jean luc
mélenchon la france insoumis seulement
la france est soumise depuis depuis
quelques mois ça a été pareil pour
l'élection présidentielle pour les
législatives n'est pas la majorité de
ces temps ci ensemble à la majorité elle
est relative mais c'est une majorité
elle tient son pouvoir elle a été élue
députée et elle est nommée par le
président la république comme ça s'est
toujours fait sous la vème république
donc on joue sur les mots je comprends
bien c'est cette voie là on s'adresse à
un public qui s'adresse aux électeurs d
les filles etc on les mobilise mais tout
ça franchement vous disiez c'est tout
une motion de censure ce toujours une
notion de posture non non il ya une
motion de censure dans notre top 1962
c'est un cartel des noms qui est hostile
à un texte imposé par le général de
gaulle et qui fait tomber le
gouvernement de georges pompidou s'est
pas toujours c'est la seule fois qu'une
motion de censure a fait tomber un
gouvernement mais là vous êtes dans
quelque chose qui à priori dont on sait
très bien que elle ne va pas être être
votée qui nous plombe pas la majorité
kéké juste une manière en réalité de
compte et c'est juste une manière de
compter les minutes qui vont qui vont la
voter et de resserrer un peu les rangs
du côté du côté des nobles et anticiper
d'éventuels dislocation des nuls c'est
tout il me semble que cette
communication ptic parce qu'il s'agit de
communication politique de la part de la
france a soumis êtes un risque parce que
elle est basée sur des mensonges alors
je suis désolé de reprendre ce terme est
logique puisque c'était le rassemblement
national qui l'avait mis en place mais
c'est vrai quand jean-luc mélenchon dit
élisez moi premier ministre tout est
faux il a fait une campagne des
législatives sur ce mot d'ordre ensuite
quand ils disent ils n'ont pas la
majorité vous êtes une anomalie
démocratique cfod donc à partir de quel
moment les électeurs on se rende compte
que finalement ceux pour qui il milite
menthe et et placent leurs messages sur
encore une fois des choses qui sont
fausses ça pose un problème démocratique
de légitimité pour la france d'un soit
mise alors c'est intéressant visa parce
qu'ils mangent risque politique pour la
nuque moi je pense que c'est intéressant
pour la nuque moche page pas d'accord je
pense que ça montre l'union pour la
troisième fois ils montrent leur union
au démarrage
candidature commune aux commissions
notamment la commission des finances est
là maintenant on va voir exactement ça
montre l'union ça l'effet positionner en
première force d'opposition ce qui ne
sont pas globalement dans les faits
puisque c'est un groupement par rapport
aux arènes normalement ils sont pas la
première force là ils s'opposent pour
voter si le rn si l'url ne votent pas et
on a déjà quand même vu des choses qui
se sont passées de députés d'ensemble
qui ont voté pour des députés du rn pour
les faire passer à la vice-présidence ça
met un peu tout le monde dans le même
panier c'est à dire qu'il ya lannux et
en face et à cette espèce de conglomérat
qui va du centre droit jusqu'à l'extrême
droite ça refait ce clivage gauche
radicalisée face à un ensemble en même
temps qui est beaucoup plus à droite
personne n'est dupe c'est une stratégie
moi je parle pas d'une réussite ou quoi
j'analyse juste ce qui était en train de
se passer est à l'étude
pour réaliser jusqu'au bout parce que ce
qu'ils opposent c'est un projet de
société parce que je vous le dise et des
subventions on va pas y arriver jusqu'au
bout ce qui va se poser comme question
c'est le partage des richesses qu est ce
qui est en train de se tramer parce
qu'il ya une pénurie de main d'oeuvre
comme vous le dites il va falloir être
très globale les entreprises justement
c'est d'abord les entreprises oui ont
décidé c'est ça ça va se positionne face
à ce que ça va sûrement ça va sûrement
se poser à l'assemblée c'est plus de
gens regardent ne surestimons pas le
bien servir ning en matière de même un
certain
certain nombre de projets du
gouvernement qui justement pour tous là
dessus sur le lundi passé le partage des
richesses mais ce que je voulais dire
c'est que pour rester dans la stratégie
je pense qu'au contraire ce que savent
c'est que ce que ça amène c'est que ça
légitime encore un peu plus ce
rassemblement national comme force
d'opposition
normalisée
et sa cote est de macron non mais si mes
personnages mais non mais écoutez
écoutez ce que écouter ce que je viens
de dire bardet là où marine le pen à
propos de la faire justement de eu d
hubert l'x et on voit bien que c'est pas
du tout un allié du gouvernement mais au
contraire ils s'imposent il s'oppose en
force d'opposition constructive alors
que les gens se disent mal à nu pour
garder ses des coups d'éclat la nuit
profond ils sont restés dans la
stratégie qui était la leur lorsqu'il
était ultra minorité c'est pas comme ça
qu'on va voir ce que ça fait sur
l'élection les voir s'il fallait
structure fois
la stratégie de la nouvelle est
effectivement celle ci c'était hier cdc
d'essayer à tout prix d'acculer les
adversaires politiques les maîtres le
dos au mur et quand même d'avoir je
dirais le grand ministère de la parole
et d'être ceux qui qui qui mène la danse
politique mais je voudrais revenir à ce
que disent les gens parce que moi quand
même j'ai une déception quand j'ai
écouté large et pas écouté la totalité
du discours donc peut être une partie de
la preuve du disco la première miss m'a
échappé mais ce que vous avez dit jean
elle ne l'a pas dit c'était elle n'a pas
dit je ne suis pas une anomalie
démocratique et voilà pourquoi je ne le
suis pas elle a répondu sur un autre
terrain qui est justement celui des
subventions et les aides et là je trouve
que ça manque de légitimité au fond elle
prête elle même le flanc à ce procès en
légitimité
bon on termine là dessus merci beaucoup
à tous les trois déjà participé à ce
premier débat la tentation du sauveur
histoire d'une passion française ça
c'est le livre de genre
garrigues le voici et
référence à superdupont vous superdupont
s'est soldée rubrique à brac cette
référence et puis la france contre
elle-même c'est le livre de richard
wehrli essai publié aux éditions grasset